wenn wir jetzt einfach die djs bergmann
warum was mache ich denn haus und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
minecraft online wir spielen heute
mühlen die gesehen wieder einen sich
nach vorige ports hat er recht ich habe
euch mal das landeslabor ein hier
dargestellt wird es gibt einfach leute
können sich pforten und wird wie mich
die sich nicht putten kann ich habe mir
natürlich weil ich ein kreatives genie
bin nicht wirklich heute eine challenge
ausgesucht ihr wisst es dass ich es bin
wer es und es muss es machen bei
fluglinien vergleich l und deswegen
deswegen lautet die heutige challenge
dass ich jemanden erst dann töten darf
wenn ich aus seiner aus seinem namen
einen fluglinien vergleich gemacht habe
das heißt ich muss leute ich muss die
leute finden
also was etwas finden ich finde die
leute auch so die eheleute finden mich
irgendwer findet irgendwie wir kämpfen
aber ich darf sie erst töten möchte
protest gegen die kämpfen
wenn ich den flug einen vergleich aus
dem namen gemacht haben ist es nicht so
bei ja es ist super okay okay okay okay
hinkommt einer wohl was passt blogs wie
eine microsoft will dieses mit dem los
die junge joho wie habt ihr das gesehen
yahoo nein nein nein nein nein ich nicht
okay ich wollte euch es aber nicht
vorenthalten
ich wollte alles nicht es nicht
als würde ich nicht zu den video
days.com leone witz was war das gerade
eben der bau jetzt war ich brauche jetzt
einfach mal eine pille
eigentlich würde ich sagen aber von ihr
was für pin nummern wie die pille die
partie brauchte man damit das nicht so
schnell geben dem nachwuchs
was habe ich okay auf jeden fall die
flut ihren challenge geht weiter super
dieb sowohl kreativ und authentisch und
riehl und baked potatoes durchaus auch
am start
sechs minuten das reicht auch aus um
sich mal ein bisschen das gefühl wenn
ich diese gut laufe werde ich nie
angegriffen
es sei denn so wie in einem offenen
versucht den ich heute schneiderin
starten das meine ich genau target nrw a
a target r
wie die fluglinie von einer
supermarktkette wer hat es verstanden
von euch setzen sein okay meine
lieblingsbahn sprich 21 es ist nichts
für mich ich ziehe einfach eine session
aber kriegt zwei es ist nichts gut habe
ich schon bio dahinten tränke brauen ich
bin ich auch versorgt was brauche ich
eigentlich noch ein bisschen rüstung
durch noch mitnehmen
er hat nicht so mich nicht schlecht
jammern rüstungs händler ist jemand in
der nähe bin okay was kann ich denn
gebrauchen konnte er noch mit
helm ist gut so super essen sparen was
los im slot ökonomisch denken ganz
wichtig spart euch los es ist wichtig
ich hab es ist wichtig als wäre ich von
großer bedeutung
übrigens ich bemerkte dass die fans
heute perfekt zur kappe passt das zwar
nie aufgefallen dass sich eine kappe in
der im farbton meines face com rahmens
ab und da ist der erste test erst
erzählt der kuki mafia er ist ein mafia
handlanger wie jemand wie die fluglinie
die mafiosi die hand gibt ok sehr schön
habe ich noch schön die puschen
einsetzen und in gold ab hatte er unter
hin dass der nächste so so jetzt geht
richtig los jetzt geht's richtig los ist
in dem werner nein wer ist der bedarf
doktor gott bedarf doktor ist ein
verzehr kann man fast er verletzt ist
ein verrat eher wie eine fluglinie in
der nur mediziner pflege noah legt ein
bisschen in der luft aber ich nehme sich
über ganz ehrlich es ist kein ding es
ist nichts wo er boxer etwa ja komm ich
höre kommt noch einer ist gelaufen
radfahrer ist scheiße ich hab so wenig
dass ich muss ich muss dem turnaround
geben hilft nichts hilft nichts genauso
ja noch ein nein seit er noch geschafft
bohr junge dass man ein overkill change
verstoßen
ich habe auch seinem namen keine
fluglinie vergleich gemacht weist unter
stress schon gott oh gott oh gott ich
muss alles wegwerfen was ich von dem
hatte alles wohin in einen behält er
behält er wie eine fluglinie die im
fundbüro nicht hergibt weil sie die
dinge behält hat die in verstanden ja es
war super es keine endlos so weitergehen
na gut dann können wir uns die sache
genau definieren recht jungen mann tun
ja hier ist gut erfüllen die niemand
oder doch
das tut weh die guten sachen vor allem
nein da schon gut behalten
ja ich brauche den worten ich bin ok hat
keiner gesehen hat kann er gesehen aber
wenn alles alles weggeworfen alles was
sie von ihm bekommen
wer treibt alter schwede
und noch eine minute zeit man ich hab
nicht mehr viel zeit was ist los
entführt mir sehr leid dass ich die
challenge cup hinein habe ich die
verkackt nein ich habe nur einmal nicht
aufgepasst es ist nicht gleichbedeutend
mit verpacken als würde ich auch mal
gewinnen und das ist der fall es ist der
fall als das hört nie auf wenn er es
darauf anlegt können den ganzen tag so
wie in dieser sprache
aber das ist auch gut so hat seine
ordnung ok alles da meine zeit geht ab
das heißt ist es keines bauern das seht
ihr übrigens auf einem rechenfehler
leben eurer zeit wenn der fall grüne es
heißt das dass sie allein am spawn seit
weil wir mehr als einer aus bonn es
funktioniert das laden nicht ist der
allerdings rot dann ist jemand in der
unmittelbaren nähe
ich weiß gar nicht wie beim fußball
entfernt sein muss damit der der in der
mitte ist noch laden kann
aber ich glaube es würde mich also viel
sein das heißt wer der feuerrot wird der
war voll grünen rennt um euer leben
und dann müssen auch noch in die
richtige richtung rennen zum beispiel
jetzt wenn er da kommt aus china
der kurze text wo habe treffen aber gut
du hast noch nicht viel equipment
thorsten fink mit dass ich so gut du
wirst und das getränke hat getränke und
alter schwede wir haben ihn ja nein
nachhinein leute ihr wisst was der fall
ist ich habe keinen flug die entwickler
ihr seinem namen gemacht das heißt alles
wegwerfen
die die asche istanbuls alter ich könnte
so op sein nein mann ich denke die
gerade wird wird so viel action action
action selection
ich würde sagen wir machen es anders ich
werfen münze wo ihr liegt um eine andere
gehabt weil ich die ganze zeit besucht
habt gut zu wissen
okay wir improvisieren jetzt werfen die
münze oder kommt ein gegner der hatten
gedroht
haha diesmal wieder an der zeit erkannt
also die methode funktioniert so okay
ich hab ich grad auslösen ob ich die
dinge vom andere wegwerfen darf ich
erstmal wie heißt du offizieller tobi
offiziell r
wie die fluglinie der vereinten
deutschen staaten nation
kennt ihr die csu per ok den habe ich
dessen sache dafür vorbehalten
wie machen es in der anderen also auf
jeden fall die djs muss weg aber die
sticks und die dias sind neue glaube ich
die sind neu die dürftig behalten
okay wir werfen uns aber hier die münze
ich weiß nicht okay hier
wir werfen den deckel von meiner livecam
hier microsoft wenn die seite kommt da
bis behalten wenn die andere seite kommt
die unebene habe ich nicht behalten
ich versuche das für euch so zu machen
als ich sehen könnt ok und ja andere
seite ich darf mich behalten super-g
das heißt dann wäre ich einfach mal okay
geil es gibt es nur noch den anderen und
mich dann wäre jetzt einfach den die djs
bergmann
warum was mache ich denn aus
manchmal ist das leben echt hart aber es
geht weiter es geht weiter kann mir das
hier anziehen
ich hoffe das war nicht von den anderen
typen falls doch schreibt mir ein brief
an sebastian wohnhaften 02558 mettenberg
in welcher sparte genau bayernstraße
fünf dahin schreiben einfach dann oder
ist es von lissabon wo ist da ist
letzter gegner nein nein nein nein ich
klicke ich gesehen ich hab's geschafft
pauli kommt dass die schwerter heißt das
schon die ganze zeit
ich verstehe es nicht okay leute das war
eine sehr tobago folge heute hat mir gut
gefallen wenn es euch auch gefallen hat
gerne den daumen nach oben da las und
die kommentare schreiben
was ich falsch gemacht habe er ist wird
mir leid falls etwas falsch war
haut rein macht gut